- Well, I have to ask
about another big movie
that you've got coming this fall
cause I'm a nerd about Marvel.
And Marvel's "The Eternals"
I mean you're in that.
So, how cool is that?
- That's like a shocking,
it's beyond cool.
I think, it's a miracle.
(Kelly laughs)
- And I love it, that I'm in the one
Marvel movie that is completely diverse.
- [Kelly] I love that.
- And it's very different
than all the other ones.
- I'm gonna love it I am such a freak fan
for all of it and I
don't think it's crazy.
I'm not behind the scenes in
the actor world or whatever.
So I don't know like as
far as casting but I think
it's so normal to see you
in something like that.
So, but you've say it-
- But Kelly, can I ask
you a question, I'm sorry.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I know I'm not supposed
to be interviewing you
but how cool it is that
our director for that movie
it's the second woman that actually
wins an Oscar for best director.
(audience clapping)
- That's amazing.
- [Selma] That's amazing,
Yeah, I'm super proud.
- [Kelly] Wow, I bet, no, that's
amazing, that's incredible.
- [Selma] Innovation.
- Exactly. And it's like
such great progress.
Like I think sometimes we get, you know
kind of bummed out a bit as females too
like, as far as equal pay and other things
like in the entertainment industry.
And it's really cool when
we like focus on that
the positive things like
that, that's really cool.
I cannot wait to see it,
I'm very excited, no joke.
Everyone here will tell you
I'm a nerd about Marvel stuff.
So